I see that all the time I have never
found that to be useful advice forget
the first 100 words you can't treat
random people as tutors today I want to
talk about 25 tips to learn a foreign
language this is based on a blog post
written by Mark Manson someone pointed
out that this was a an interesting
collection of tips for language learning
so I thought it would be interesting to
go through these 25 tips and give you my
take on these tips how relevant how
useful they are bear in mind that
language learning is very personal so
what I like or dislike may not be the
same as what you like or dislike or what
Mark Manson likes or dislikes his first
tip is conversation conversation
conversation now he was I think living
in buenus and faced with the difficulty
of communicating with locals so in that
situation if you're in a country where
the language is spoken and you need to
learn that language of course you take
advantage of every opportunity to use
the language however as a strategy for
learning the language I have never
considered conversation at least in the
initial stages to be the key because you
can't have a conversation if you don't
understand what the other person is
saying so I am much more inclined to
prefer heavy input based approach to
language learning and wait until you
have a high enough level of
comprehension to where you can have
adult conversations with people and at
that point yes you do need to speak a
lot the second thing he says this
intensity of study Trump's length of
study well intensity yes and I do
remember when I was learning am Mandarin
Chinese I had three hours a day
one-on-one with the teacher and then I
would spend five or six or seven hours
on my own listening and reading and
writing and learning characters and I
learned in one year faster than other
diplomatic students as with the Canadian
government in Hong Kong who who took two
years and learned less well so I I
remember I came to the conclusion at
that time that creating that white heat
in your brain that comes from intensity
is very helpful but we continue to learn
so even after a period of very intense
learning it continues to gestate in your
brain and there are other opportunities
to use the language and you are always
improving over a long long period of
time number three he says classes suck
and are an inefficient use of time and
money one on one as the way I had it in
Hong Kong with a teacher a new teacher
every hour forcing me to say something
in the language I think that was very
good very intense however sitting in a
classroom with 10 people with a teacher
especially if you have to travel a half
hour or 45 minutes to get to the class
the classes are expensive in my case the
government was paying if I had to pay
for that myself I wouldn't do it because
we can achieve so much on our own
listening and reading and then
eventually finding an opportunity to use
the language number four know your
motivation for learning a new language
that's important I was listening to a
podcast how stuff works or something
something two Americans and they were
saying why would you learn a language is
it just for showing off no that's I
don't think why most people learn
languages but it may be the case for
some so you have to look at yourself am
I learning this language to show off am
I learning to communicate with my
grandmother am I learning it because I
need it for work am I learning it
because I'm interested in the culture
it's important to understand why you're
doing it because there are a lot of
moments during the process when you are
discouraged because you don't think
you're getting anywhere and you have to
go back to like why am I actually doing
it so that's a good point number five he
says set learning goals well I've said
that in a general sense my goal always
is B2 on the European common framework
of reference which is kind of fluent
with mistakes and places where you don't
understand that to me is the goal once
you're there you can continue to improve
but I very often don't achieve that I
move off a language where I'm still at
A2 and I go to another language because
I'm interested in it so to me at my
stage the goals aren't that important
when I was a Canadian government
language student in Hong Kong learning
Mander in Chinese I had a very specific
goal I had to write the British foreign
service exam and I said I want to do
that within a year so that was a very
specific goal for a specific purpose
that's not the situation now and the
goal will dictate what you do are you
going to spend a lot of time writing are
you going to maintain a diary all the
different things that you can do many of
which are hard work if your goal is high
enough you will have the discipline to
do these things if you're more of a
diletant like me you'll be more of a
lazy language learner like I am next
thing he says start with the most common
words the 100 most common words I see
that all the time I have never found
that to be useful advice if you are
doing a lot of listening and reading or
even speaking you will encounter the
most common 100 words 500 Words very
very often however the frequency
declines very quickly and the major
challenge thereafter is going to be
acquiring the less frequent words but
the most common words they look after
themselves you needn't worry about it
and if your goal is to learn the most
common 100 words so that you can go and
start talking to someone you will find I
think in many most cases that you won't
be able to follow the conversation
anyway because the person you're
speaking to is not going to limit what
they have to say to the 100 most common
words number seven he says carry a
pocket dictionary I never carry a pocket
dictionary dictionaries are very
inefficient it takes time to find a word
you forget what the meaning was as soon
as you close the dictionary I just find
you know you end up saying how do you
say this how do you say that could you
please repeat and you kind of struggle
through if you have that kind of a
rudimentary conversation I prefer to
prepare myself through lots of listening
and reading and then hope for the best
so I don't carry a pocket dictionary
number eight keep practicing the new
language in your head again I never do
that not deliberately now it may be that
that subconsciously I have these phrases
bouncing around in my head but I don't
deliberately try to practice the new
language in my head I just don't do that
that's not to say it's not a good thing
to do it's just not something that I can
you know do you're going to say a lot of
stupid things I accept it yeah I'm not
sure it's stupid but we are comfortable
in our own language typically we feel we
are if we're adults we think we're adult
we think we're intelligent we think we
can express ourselves and all of a
sudden in a new language we can't we
make mistakes we can't find the word
in a way it's unpleasant although there
is the sort of compensating sense of
achievement when in fact you are able to
say something you are able to understand
you get this tremendous power but yeah
there's certainly periods of uncertainty
and you have to accept that number 10 he
says figure out pronunciation patterns
and he makes reference to Slavic
languages and romance languages which
have certain patterns I would rather
here say when it comes to pronunciation
focus on intonation if you can get the
int ation of a language the rhythm of
the language then the pronunciation is
going to improve your correct usage is
going to improve you should you know
listen to that intonation and try to
imitate it number 11 he says use audio
and online courses for the first 100
Words and basic grammar well I've cover
the first 100 words I don't think that's
important they'll come at you anyway
basic grammar again it's hard to nail
down the basic grammar you'll be
struggling with basic grammar for a long
long time he mentions various apps he
doesn't mention link unfort Ely fine
yeah there's all kinds of apps and tools
and resources online that are going to
help you but the focus should be on
acquiring the language not necessarily
just the first 100 words not necessarily
the basic grammar both of those things
are going to continue to elude you for
quite a while number 12 he says after
the first 100 words focus on becoming
conversational again I don't know what
that means you are not going to be
conversational with 100 words forget the
first 100 words even forget trying to be
conversational at at an early stage
focus on improving your comprehension
acquiring vocabulary speak when you have
the opportunity you're not going to be
comfortably conversational until you
have a sufficient vocabulary and a
sufficient level of comprehension he say
aim for the brain melt sure I think I
understand what he's saying go at it as
intensively as you can and you will be
engaging with the language it's kind of
occupying your every waking moment and
interestingly whatever you've done
before going to bed or during the day
during the sleeping hours that is being
reinforced and put into your long-term
memory so the more intense that
experience the bigger the brain melt I
guess the faster you're socking it into
your brain use the new language daily
only in the sense that listening and
reading are also using the language it's
simply not practical to be speaking
daily but you should try to maintain
some consistency of engaging with the
language and so that's certainly good
advice number 15 how do you say X is the
most important sentence you can possibly
learn again I don't agree with that how
do you say X is not difficult to say you
will learn that early but it's not a
major help I think you'll find yourself
saying I beg your pardon could you
repeat that more often because when we
speak we tend to limit ourselves to what
we can say and the words that we have
number 16 he says one-on-one tutoring is
the best and most efficient use of time
it's the best and most efficient type of
tutoring or classroom learning
one-on-one I don't believe in sitting
with a group of five or six or 10 and
taking turns conversing some are better
than others not an efficient use of time
but I think that listening reading or
dare I say using link can be at least as
efficient to use of time as one-on-one
tutoring but you need a mixture you need
them all the tutor is stimulating it's
feedback it's it's all good number 17
date someone who speaks the target
language and not your native language uh
I'm married so it doesn't apply you're
selectively you know removing anyone who
speaks English if your native language
is English harder to find I'm not sure
how relevant that is as a activity 18 if
you can't find someone cute who will put
up with you find a language buddy online
trou with a language buddy is again I
have to spend time teaching that person
my language English so that's an hour
for every hour I get of speaking to them
in my target language I would rather
spend more time with input activities
and then pay pay $10 $15 $20 an hour for
an online tutor when I want Facebook
Chat Plus Google translate equals
winning again I'm not on Facebook I
don't have any interest in Facebook uh
Google Translate is useful for written
communication I think is a little
cumbersome trying to use it for oral
communication number 20 when you learn a
new word try to use it a few times right
away again a big part of language
learning to me is that it' be natural I
acquire so many words through through
listening and reading I can't possibly
use them all right away there's no
opportunity to use them there's a
gradual process where words that we have
seen and we're starting to become
familiar with eventually become passive
vocabulary and eventually become active
vocabulary I don't think you can Short
Circuit the process by trying to use
them right away and if you do you'll
only slow down your acquisition of a
richer and richer passive vocabulary
which is a base that you need for
comprehension and it's the base upon
which all other language skills are
built so no don't try to use it right
away 21 he says TV shows movies
newspapers magazines are good
supplements but he says ultimately
nothing compares to the benefits of
speaking like conversations again I
don't agree with that because if you're
into TV shows movies newspapers and
magazines you're expanding your horizons
getting used to that new language and
everything associated with it if you
limit yourself to what you can say it
becomes a much more limited experience
and I don't think that's a good
long-term strategy number 22 most people
are helpful let them help yeah most
people are helpful but that French girl
who went to Norway she makes the point
and it's very important you know make
sure you're good before you get there so
if you go to Norway and you aren't very
good in Norwegian as helpful as I am
sure the Norwegians are they're going to
speak to you in English because they
think they're being helpful by speaking
to you in English so you can't treat
random people as tutors you have to get
yourself to a level where people are
comfortable speaking to you in the
language that you're trying to learn
number 23 there will be a lot of
ambiguity and miscommunication yes of
course there will that's comes with the
territory as I mentioned earlier that
uncertainty that's part of learning a
language and we shouldn't let it bother
us 24 these are the phases you go
through to learn foreign language I mean
you can describe the phases any way you
want in my view we have initial success
because from zero suddenly we understand
a few things where able to say a few
things then we go through a phase where
we feel we're not making any progress
whatsoever because there's so many low
frequency words that we need in order to
understand a movie in order to have
meaningful conversations and then all of
a sudden we turn a corner and we have
this feeling of wow I'm somewhere I'm B2
and these phases may be different for
different people but there is a gradual
process of working towards success
however we Define it and finally he says
number 25 find a way to make it fun I
would not put that as finally I would
put that as upfront figure out a way to
enjoy the process and at every stage and
we talked about stages enjoy the process
so I for example at an early stage uh I
find it enjoyable to listen to our Min
stories over and over again comes a
point where I can no longer do that
because we need repetition but we need
new things and so I find it enjoyable to
move onto things that are difficult
where I'm meeting some of the same words
and phrases but in many different
contexts and I'm learning about many
things through the language and I find
that enjoyable obviously when I have an
opportunity to use the language if I'm
in the country or if I hear someone
speaking a language that I've been
learning I'll immediately pounce on them
and speak to them and so that's also
enjoyable so it's important at every
stage to find ways to enjoy the process
not just finally but even at the very
beginning everyone has their own
approach to language learning if it
works for them that's all that matters
and I'm going to leave with you two
videos that I would suggest you have a
look at talking about the importance of
input because I think that's crucial and
that kind of underlies my philosophy of
language learning thanks for listening
bye for now